hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i
am actually live chat don't tell anybody
pretend this is just a youtube video
okay you guys
stop it
i wanted to do another kind of live
review of
the new outer worlds dlc which is
supposed to be a murder mystery which is
something that i
absolutely love by live review i
basically just mean
i kind of point out the notes that i
would if i were actually reviewing
something because i was a professional
game reviewer for almost a decade but
haven't been for
about three years now but that's kind of
the idea is like openly just talk
through the things that i would bring up
in a review while playing live i do also
have to mention
that this is sponsored by razer again if
you're watching the youtube video you
hear more from them in the middle if
you're here on twitch chat
um you know you heard all about it
captain i hope dr wells has not dragged
you into one hello
welcome back captain cool how can i be
of assistance
i would like to know about the murder
please certainly captain
i was hoping you would ask me too
very cool i'm into it already
[Music]
it's like one division but video game an
interesting style choice
and a lady's butt forsaken parasites
and those two informants had brought me
to rizzo's distillery
but it wasn't just the triple distilled
deliciousness of rizzo spectrum brand
vodka that i found there
that's a sentence that somebody wrote
and i like it
that was a very cool choice i like that
who was it who was it show me show me
a special investigation must be
concluded first
very good i bet you the writers had a
great time with this
we have a communication coming in from
one administrator ludovico
beautiful get off the transmission
cedric
we agreed to let me do the negotiating
lobby with you friend i am administrator
ludovico of the famed aerodanos
atmospheric complex
murder is a stain on the rizzo's brand
she was scheduled to unveil our newest
product spectrum brown
before this tragic event but we cannot
move forward with our unveiling until we
apprehend the killer
the narrative consistency oh wow
is that like i i really love this game
like i
enjoyed it so much i don't know about
dlc yet obviously but uh
the consistency of having somebody's
murder still even just
be about a product she was scheduled to
unveil on us products spectrum brown
before this traffic event
cannot move forward without unveiling
until we apprehend the killer
well i would just like to do it we don't
need to fight back that hard
okay unexpectedly
yeah sorry about the frame rate this is
the it's because it's 7 20. it's not the
game's fault this game runs beautifully
i mean we had like nosy
hello hello there hope your atmospheric
entry wasn't too troublesome
as a guest of honor you deserve the best
in comfort where did you pop up from
okay we're doing it it's a murder
mystery and it's happening
bellhop norville is the first man we've
seen can you tell me about the movie hi
i was the one who found helen's body in
the grand ballroom
corpse wasn't in the best shape
aside from that i don't know a whole lot
what what time was supposed to host the
unveiling for rizzo's newest product
spectrum brown
until you catch the killer the unveiling
has been indefinitely postponed
helen's death has been a shock for many
a lot of people are
inconsolable hell even black hole birdie
helen's bow has wandered off
some folks think he had something to do
with the murder but
yeah i don't believe it once you're
ready head down to the lobby the
ballroom is just behind the elevators
meanwhile i'll grab your bags bags uh
you're
making fun right your luggage
belongings kits wherever you keep what
you ain't wearing
you're still giving me a pretty blanket
yeah my face is
suppose it's not i don't know what
you're talking about fam
do you just wear the same set of clothes
okay well we don't
okay somebody committed about a bellhop
novel
can we just stick to the important
things because yes i have been wearing
this for a while okay can we just
you know all right one step at a time
so i will say at first um
very into the murder mystery they've got
me into it i also think this is just
really pretty
a lot of colors not that this game
wasn't space colorful anyway but i feel
like this is a lot more color
than um the rest of the game and
certainly a unique setting
um i'm very very
into the western vibe of the the hotel
murder mystery and all that good stuff
you know that's inconsolable gonna be
her bow
oh oh thank the law inspector you don't
know how relieved i am to see you
at your service constable keane it's
good to meet you in person inspector
dr goodnight ecstatic to make your
various acquaintances and so on
are we finished with the pleasantries
there's something i'm excited to show
you
i like you what's the cause of death
great stuff lady must have riled up
someone
helen was killed by a poison a blow to
the head and a plasma weapon
possibly more i'm a huge fan developed a
device
which may prove useful in your
investigation our office has instructed
her to hand it over to you
our office has instructed you to hand it
over to you oh please you make it sound
as if i'm turning over stolen goods
i've met the love of my life my
discrepancy amplifier
hold it in your hands feel the way it
hums with ontological potential
you're perfect the discrepancy amplifier
uses a deterministic model of our
universe to detect the discrepancy
between what should be and what
actually is then it renders any
discrepancies visible by using the power
of
magnification that doesn't make sense
but i will let you
finish but now before i tell you all
about the razer keo
pro which i am really excited to use
mostly because it has an adaptive light
sensor and my
uh really big monitor makes it difficult
to have a correct lighting setup
uh whereas this webcam has one
built into it this fhd usb webcam can
detect how bright or dark its
surroundings are and adjust accordingly
for picture-perfect clarity
every time it also has uncompressed
1080p 60fps
and offers a level of visual fidelity
that's as sharp as it is smooth
for the most optimal video quality and
viewer experience you can get it also
has hdr enabled at 30 frames a second
so you can make your stream pop more
with vibrant colors by activating hdr at
30 frames a second
it ramps up your video's dynamic range
while correcting over and under exposed
areas and i should mention it is really
designed for streamers it even says that
on the box it's very
uh streaming or youtubing setup friendly
including with a wide-angle lens
with adjustable fov so you can show more
of your shot if you would like to and
i'm giving one away check out the link
in the description below to where you
can get one yourself or
enter the giveaway a huge thanks to
razer for sponsoring the stream and back
to the video
okay greetings expected thanks to the
half genius hop mad scientific mind of
dr goodnight
uh you've been granted the discrepancy
amplifier a handy investigation device
for uncovering clues
through eric donos be sure to equip the
discrepancy amplifier in a weapon slot
before you continue hunting
yeah i imagine this isn't gonna have
much combat in it um
so we're gonna go inventory all right
this evidence has been recorded for a
later reference this is really neat like
i love that they invented a new mechanic
for this dlc like that's that's great
um don't patronize me
okay well i wasn't actually done this
footprint
of the grand ballroom typically the
ballroom is clean
twice daily which means this must have
been made by either helen or haracell
no seem like large
shoes footprint is a tailor-made 8.75
suggesting that its owner was very
particular about their shoe size that's
an interesting number the exact size
that halcyon helen
probably helen's then the following
compounds have been detected
purpleberry residue nitrogen-rich
fertilizer
common grass okay so she was walking
around outside first probably
you know these designers know what
they're doing
was she hopping like was this a jump
jump jump um
[Music]
those are very specific footsteps
um i want to go speak to bell boy again
finally check didn't i see i hope you're
fond of the penthouse it's
pretty much the best seat in the whole
hotel thank you there are puzzles in the
old
ordinately esteemed guest if my hello
were any more earnest
this loudspeaker would explode that's
right authorized floor can i bring you
to
the penthouse next stop the finest seat
in the house
cool i'm excited i'm i'm really liking
this so far
okay this is really pretty
and again i do feel like they've a
introduced a new mechanic with
this thing um be definitely chosen
a different kind of lifestyle than the
one through the main campaign like this
is a lifestyle luxury of
the player character being uh
treated well um i'm sure there's a
motive for that obviously but
uh and we've got a bunch of leads
immediately
told in a way that's tonally consistent
inspector i understand you've visited
the scene of the crime
i have halcyon helen was an important
cultural icon
she will be so you keep saying oh
sweetie your discretion is appreciated i
admit i'm beginning to feel more
confident in this arrangement
confidence i'm granting you access
through the gates to the orchards
you're officially authorized to see this
investigation through to the end
didn't know i wasn't already but okay
somebody about about to attack me up
here
i didn't expect that to be this much
combat in this kind of area
these orchids are not well policed huh
watch what you do with that thing sam
beautiful i know i should be looting
but i'm really just here to solve a
murder okay you know
okay i don't feel like the combat really
does fit in with the narrative here
i actually didn't expect it to have any
combat in this
area i mean the truth is that like you
know the galaxy is overrun with things
that might attack you but i don't feel
like those were like native to this area
maybe they'll make it fit into the story
but um
you know having combat right there
certainly did feel like a weird choice
to me
okay these footprints match the shoes
previously
analyzed in the grand ballroom there is
a one hundred ten percent chance but
they ten percent
and they were left by ruth bellamy the
actress known as halcyon helen
okay helen was in a hurry
so that's the same imprints that we had
in the ballroom as she's rushing around
basically
um the tracks hesitate partially turning
in one spot as if helen paused to look
behind her she may have feared she was
being followed interesting
hmm maybe i'll just it did say she
turned
just walk around with my scopes out ah
there it is okay
such lovely weather calls for a harvest
somebody's dead
jacob you shut your mouth
whoa you a cool design
i have some regrets where attacking them
was concerned though
no leave me alone not today
my weird crab ape friend
leave me alone trying to solve crimes
good day are you out there yes
the majority of your mental capacity
everyone's so sassy okay
did you get in here you're not a rizzo's
authorized
avoid it all what does it even matter
now
what do you want speak up and quickly if
you will
you know what i want a murderer
no wait a victim was here portrayed by
the late actress
ruth bellamy yeah i do yes one can't be
too short with so many symbols what are
sassy women out here
of course if you were to say contract
your services to me
i suppose i could grant you clearance
enough to answer your murder-related
questions
ms inspector okay you see
i found myself in a bit of a pickle some
of my lab techs have turned rather
aggressive
following a recent experiment gone awry
hence why i've barricaded myself
that's what's happened outside um what
goes on in these research labs
yeah yeah let's do that excellent you
have my gratitude and
soon you'll have my knowledge of miss
bellamy's recent visit i hope so
someone was following who was it
i believe you can dispense a sedative
gas from a terminal in the utility room
infestation
i'm trying to sedate you all if you
everyone can just chill
i don't want any of this you know i'm
genuinely trying to knock you out so you
guys don't have to
be this way i'm sorry
we didn't want it to be like this
at least it's pretty i would love to be
friends with you but i can't do that
while you're trying to kill me and i'm
trying i'm just trying to help
okay sedative gas beautiful
i've done it
yeah i'm not going to mess with you you
crap i'm just trying to find out what
happened to the woman who was murdered
wait what wait what what do you think
dr blossom on the other side of this
door
how am i who just committed a crime
what happened somebody didn't want us
talking to dr blossom
timeline discrepancy detected i didn't
see that coming
the motor is here like right now
damn that's intense
and then this person's already left
nobody's got any security cameras
[Music]
body heat readings indicate that the
culprit was just here mere moments
earlier in the timeline
hmm it looks like a stamp they left
the great somebody around my size could
have crawled in wouldn't have been
comfortable or
you know clean what are you doing in
here
oh oh sorry that was actually an
accident
what are you oh sweet
shimmering law where'd you come from
sorry let me just get back in character
it's a mascot got it okay ah
that was an accident oh [ __ ] i guess not
my [ __ ]
um all right well can i meet you there
right now because i would like to know
whatever it is that you know good sir
i would like to exit the grand colonial
uh you let me in
okay wasn't sure timeline discrepancy
oh my oh my god okay
medical analysis complete this
wow this person is fast the firearm is
unique
and does not exist in this unit's
database damn
you're just killing everybody
exotic weaponry yes inspector the
needler
the spoke handgun oh wielded by halcyon
helen
famously deployed by house stan helen in
terror on monarch
wow weapon was responsible for executing
the chief of the savages
played by spencer woolridge they're
using her gun to do it huh
this unit is incapable
[Laughter]
the plot is thickening you know there's
a lot going on a lot of people
some interesting motives um i'm into it
i feel like this is it's it's fun it's
tense like the fact that there are like
people
dying in real time around us makes it
extra cool i've not played a lot of
uh murder mysteries that do it quite to
the extent that this did it with the
the impression that someone's smart
enough to know to like lock things off
and
they all know each other and people are
dealing things somebody did in fact
commit a murder and i really like it but
we are going to end
this here thank you everyone for
watching check out the link in the
description if you're watching on
youtube
to where you can find out more about the
razer keo pro we are doing a giveaway
you could win one
which is lovely i'm very excited to
check it out uh thank you to razer for
sponsoring this
video i just pressed the escape button
when i put it down
[Laughter]
and yeah we are raising money to stop
asian american hate uh for an
organization that both studies that
and um tries to basically take on a lot
of reports
so i'll leave a link in the description
where you can find out more about that
too thank you to everyone who donated
um but otherwise i will see you all
next time